putnam in 1979 argued that the
indispensability of mathematics to
empirical science gives us a good reason
to believe in the existence of
mathematical entities according to this
line of argumentation reference to or
quantification over mathematical
entities such as sets numbers functions
and such is indispensable to our best
scientific theories and so we ought to
be committed to the existence of these
mathematical entities to do so would
otherwise would be called intellectual
dishonesty at least in putnam's mind in
1979 moreover these mathematical
entities are seen to be on the same
epistemic par with other theoretical
entities of science since belief in the
existence of the former is justified by
the same evidence that confirms the
theory as a whole this argument is known
as the quine putnam indispensability
argument for mathematical realism so
what is your opinion on this sir
well in the first
place think it's a bit unfair
to accuse
coin
goodman others of intellectual
dishonesty
because they
worked on
what they called constructive nominalism
which was an effort to reconstruct uh
our
knowledge and understanding
on
the basis with denial of the existence
of sets
i don't think that was intellectually
dishonest
i think it was quite a reasonable effort
on the part of
quine and goodman
the coin abandoned it later goodman came
to it
uh secondly if we
there's a there's considerable
difference between
numbers
sets
and
let's say atoms or
chairs uh i think
i'm sure putnam would agree
so
as he knows
knew better than i do
there's no
clear notion of said
there's a reasonably clear notion of
number putting aside
non-standard theories so we can assume
number to be understood
set is
a
famous statement by the
mathematician chronicler
that
god gave us the natural numbers
and everything else is a human creation
of course he didn't mean it literally
amen
natural numbers are just somehow there
uh
we can try to understand them but they
have their properties and so on
sets
are concepts that we develop first of
all there isn't any such thing as a set
just a set of something
then if we talk about what are the right
what's the right form of set theory
there are different approaches
so you can have an
axiomatic set theory like uh
zamelo frankel
you can have constructivist set theories
uh which just develop as
people's intuition develops
uh
they're different forms of set theory
uh
then
quite beyond that
uh take the difference between
numbers and uh
what what is postulated in uh
in scientific theories
like atoms
or
at one time in history uh phlegin
or caloric
they're different
i mean
when
say a star
can go out of existence
three can't go out of existence
if the universe
as scientists know believe
the consensus belief
if this universe is going to
end in the
darkness
end of time
everything disappears
numbers aren't going to disappear
they weren't they were there
before
uh
atoms
appeared they were there before stars
appeared
they were in some
different uh
category
so even if we accept the argument
which is reasonable
that uh
if they're
indispensable for scientific theories we
have no good reason to deny their
existence
their existence is of a very different
kind
and this kind of discussion i think just
misses that misses that distinction
which of course is what has bothered
people
what kind of exists not elsewhere
putnam regularly correctly points out
that we use the word there exists in
many different ways
and i think that's a positive here
when we talk about the existence of
numbers
the existence of stars
we're talking about very different
different
things does that mean that numbers are
somehow more real than the universe or
do we use the word real in different
ways as well
to say that something is real is just to
say that it is
real is an honorific term
so when i say
something is really true
it's no different than saying it's true
other than i emphasize it
you should believe it it's important
it's really true
if i say
numbers are real
somehow means
can't dispense with them they play a
role in our thinking
that's gone we have every
reason to suppose that
there's
some sort of such entity we have no idea
what it is